yeah i mean like i
i i i've said this before but i was
happy with my place and i i was very
lucky to find the place that i have
moved into
um but you know i was i was i was still
pretty happy with my place so
i i
it's it's to me it's definitely an
upgrade but it's like
it's it's like a natural progression to
me and i feel like there are some things
that i've definitely progressed in in
like 2021 and then there's some things
that i feel like i've probably requested
regressed in or stayed the same i don't
know it's been a it's been a weird year
because
after 2020 everyone was just like all
right ready to like hit the ground
running in 2021 and then the environment
just didn't allow
us to like hit the ground running yeah
yeah so like i remember like i think for
a lot of 2021 like like you know i can
say this now because i think before
going back to england i was definitely
burnt out like um
i'm saying it's not like i was
definitely burnt out and everyone's just
everyone's just like oh why didn't you
take a holiday why why didn't you take
some time off to uh just look after your
mental health and all that stuff and
what i would say was there was nothing i
could do
there was nothing that i wanted to do
because what i wanted to do was see
family see friends
back at home like two years a long time
two years is a very long time and that
was like that's that was like my reset
right so before that like i was
definitely burnt out and i kind of just
dealt with it by just trying to fill up
my schedule and uh kind of kind of just
like ignoring it and i i didn't fully
realize that until i went back to
england and i just had nothing on my
schedule and i just realized
holy [ __ ] this is uh this is really
refreshing i'm getting a lot of ideas
and i want to go back to work
is this what it's like to uh have a
break have a proper break this is what
it's like to have a life
to just not do anything
yeah so i mean that's that's kind of
like what has been hardest in 2021
because 2020 was
like what was the year where you know
the entire world was flagged 2021 was
like me waiting for the world to get
back to normal and it's funny
finally
finally looking like it is going to get
back to normal now yeah fingers crossed
touchwood are you are you boys happy
with your youtube channel this year
yeah
which one joey which one
i i love it because uh 2021 is the year
that joey befine finally became an
antituber yeah
just just not on the end of the just not
on the anime man channel yeah yeah i
have uh
i told gant about it but uh because i've
been uploading a lot more on my second
channel now and i've been making a lot
more anime content on my second channel
now that i have a playlist on my second
channel called actual anime content
it's just a poke fun but like yeah i
don't know um
i'm very harsh on myself when it comes
to my youtube channel and my content
stuff like that so like you know
i'm obviously proud of all the videos i
upload on both channels yeah otherwise i
wouldn't upload it at all but i'm
definitely i'm [ __ ] not proud of all
of them
but like i'm definitely one of those
people that's like
after a week of that like honeymoon
period i'm like yeah i could have done
better
i'll do better on the next one and then
i try and do it and i keep thinking i'm
going in the right direction then i'm
just like at the end of it i look back
at all of it i'm like
yeah like five percent of it was okay
yeah yeah 95
could have used a bit of work but i
think uh yeah like i have like plans for
next year for what i want to do with my
[ __ ] but like yeah i don't know it's uh
it's going to be scary because it's
going to be a lot different yeah like
pretty much everything i've established
up until this point so yeah see how it
goes but uh you know that's i guess
that's what we have trash taste for
right like as a fail-safe almost or uh
not so much a failsafe but like because
i guess like safety now yeah like a
safety net i guess because when we
started again as like when we started
trash days we were like oh yeah this
will be like a nice side project for you
to do you know yeah and like we could do
all sorts of cool things on the sideline
while we focus on our main content but
now it's like well we're like 1.1
million subs or something which is
insane on the main channel thank you
again by the way yeah um
it's and you know now it's like pretty
much become like the main basket now and
our
main channels and our side channels and
whatever else that we do outside of
trash taste has become the safety net
almost no like trash chase has become
like almost the number one priority no
it is a number one it is
when we need to schedule recording
that's getting done before any of my
[ __ ] videos or anything like any of
my scripts
exactly
so it's like you know definitely because
like we do have like lots of exciting
plans for trash taste obviously next
year uh which obviously can't tell you
but look forward to it um yeah i
definitely plan my work in greek my
working week around trash taste yeah not
the other way around yeah
um and i think just like that right like
that mentality is already just telling
of like this is out but yeah
but also when there's i think because
all three of us are involved i think it
i i guess we probably pay more respect
to the the scheduling of trash tastes
yeah well definitely if i [ __ ] over my
own channel that's my own problem but
yeah if i [ __ ] over the scheduling with
like trash taste yeah it's like a burden
to everyone yeah yeah and you know we
have we have people who turn up to help
us with trash taste yeah you know when i
[ __ ] around doing a monkey tear list on
my own channel you know if i don't do
that it's you know it's on me and yeah
that's it right everyone else yeah yeah
i think that that's like i guess like
going back to the whole like getting a
personal assistant yeah or like getting
a team yeah to help you know behind the
scenes of like my main channel and stuff
like that i think that's the one thing
i'm scared of which is like i'm going to
feel more pressure now to deliver on my
main channel because now it's not just
me that i'm taking care of it's taking
care of a personal assistant or like you
know an editor or you know a manager or
whoever right there's like multiple
people's livelihoods at stake right it's
like that's that's really the only thing
i guess that stopped me from personally
getting a personal assistant
to talk to them maybe they'll realize
i'm [ __ ] stupid
but like why am i helping it's a lost
cause
no like for me i think the biggest
change for me this year is i guess i've
been really trying to figure out not
what i want to do but how i want to do
it i feel like you said this last year
in the year before
is that okay for me to say
did i say this last year you definitely
definitely said this last year yeah
because i think this year has been the
year where i've really like knuckled
down to
try to really start thinking of my main
channel as like content as a job that i
have to like
break down and uh like actually be
strict on how long it takes to like make
a video because right you can't be
taking months to make one va
no i mean like it's like because because
i think one big thing that has changed
since joining trash case right is that
for better or worse my content
my content upload schedule is compared
to your guys right and like especially
like seeing how your guys's content is
made like not saying like obviously i'm
not saying like anyone's content uh is
better or worse you know it's just like
i've kind of realized that
i want to upload as much as you guys but
with with the workflow of my kind of my
style of content i've tried to like cut
as many many corners as i can and there
is like there is just too many
bottlenecks that i can't i can't do to
like to like like i've i've reached max
productivity
that i can reach with my channel and
before
last year i was like i can improve i can
do better i can do like three videos a
month and trash taste and now i've kind
of i've come to realize that
not only is that setting the wrong
expectations for me to feel like i can
do it and you know i feel bad if i don't
do it but it also like sets the wrong
expectations for the viewer as well
because if the viewers expecting me to
upload that many videos a month and i
kind of like
i kind of keep doing that
then that's that's just going to be
unsustainable and i'm just going to burn
out which which i did do this year but
that's like i didn't burn out because i
was putting myself in through too much
work i burnt out because of the world
situation but i've just realized that
i need to like i need to make a schedule
which is sustainable and
unfortunately you know it's for better
or worse like i
my upload schedule does get compared to
your guys but like i've come to i've
come to realize to not feel guilty about
that anymore yeah
you know i've when i make jokes about it
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i i don't think
it's a sound a bit of fun yeah i also
don't like i've never considered i don't
think that me or joe have ever thought
that your channel your content and
channel is comparable to ours in any way
like i don't think one upload is equal
to one upload on
no no i'm not like definitely not like
like it's it's it i guess it's like
forced me to like really break down a
workflow to like the video right because
like
how long would it take would it
how long does it take you guys to like
make one video like hour wise would you
say that varies yeah yeah that varies
literally like two hours or like a
hundred yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh there are some videos that like even
one now that's really it's like a really
big video i've been working on that i've
been wanting to do for a very long time
yeah a lot of moving pieces and a lot of
a lot of a lot of love edits and a lot
of footage to go through but you know
that no matter even if i put like a
month's worth of like like let's say if
you just took the hours i put into it
let's say it's like a
full working month of hours into one
video yeah it doesn't [ __ ] matter
because i gotta upload the week after
anyway so like yeah yeah exactly but
then maybe the week after it'll be
something that took me two hours so it's
it's kind of
you kind of have to juggle it but also
not make it look
like all these videos are like
completely different quality yeah
exactly which is why i kind of just
realized okay the only way i can make my
videos not seem drastically like
different in
uh feeling uh theme
quality production is to just have i
guess
me being an idiot and me my personality
being like the focal point yeah exactly
the video or at least the main aspect of
the video yeah sorry so like so like i
had to break down for like let's say
like the fastest video you had to break
down yeah so had to break down like my
video making process like the fastest
video you can make is like say in like
two or three hours right let's say you
like you needed to get a video out so
i've had like a few times where i just
need to get a video out right so that's
at the time on my end not doing editing
yeah yeah yeah so like for me like i
need to like pencil in let's say let's
say i'm doing a video about an anime
right so i have to pencil in hours like
around about a day to watch the anime
which like assuming it's like a season
of anime right and then let's say two
days for
two two days for scripting which is like
one day for the actual script one day to
like finish the script and actually make
it like a good script you know and uh
and so that's that's already three days
right and then i have to
have like you know two hours or so two
two hours for like the recording of the
script and then nice and then i send
that off so that's like on my end
three and a half days already
um to be sent off to the editor now the
editor edits it and he has to send it
back to me and i have to do like the
finishing touches uploads and
um finishing touches upload thumbnail on
title which if i'm really lucky would
take half a day so that's like
four days basically
of workflow from beginning to end let's
say and that's if i'm fully productive
and
nothing goes wrong right that's the
fastest i can make a video of you to
assume i don't procrastinate so that's
that's four days in a week right yeah
trash taste is one day in a week yeah
right
i also want weekends as well
so now you just wish for thinking at
that point
i've realized like in my previous years
when i've been able to do three videos a
month i've been able to do three videos
a month and trash days because i've just
i've just worked on weekends and i've
just realized i kind of want weekends
and i kind of also want to do other
things like stream and
like maybe focus on some side projects
as well and i've just realized i'm
trying to put too much on myself and
there's like with the type of video i'm
making there is no way i can make this
video faster than the way i'm making it
and people will say well why don't you
become like a personality based channel
like you know you guys where you know
you know you can do different kinds of
content that is more focused on
personality and i've played around with
that and then i've just realized no i
kind of i kind of like enjoy what i do i
kind of i i like scripting i've i am you
know i've already i've already got trash
taste i have a channel that is based
around my personality so called you know
and so i've i've just like
just realized that my main channel is
always going to be
a max cap two uploads a wee uh two
uploads a month if i'm lucky three
uploads a month and i'm not going to
feel guilty if i don't make that if it's
one upload a month because i'm traveling
or because i'm on holiday that's what
you're getting and like i guess this is
a message to you guys as well which is
i know i know like i know the image is
it's just like oh gods are late guns are
lazy bum who doesn't upload that much
but uh trust me i am working at full
capacity and you guys are getting two
uploads uh you guys are getting two
uploads a month maybe one upload a month
if i'm busy that month but that is me at
max capacity and i'm not going to try to
pretend that anything else is that you
know i honestly never saw a problem like
you know as much as i like you know
poking fun of or whatever you know in
episodes and stuff like that i honestly
never saw a problem with
your upload schedule
um because again like i know how much
work goes into the content that you make
specifically like you know you say you
take two days to make a script i
sometimes take like a week to make a
script because i'm nowhere near as good
as making a script
the two-day script happened this year oh
yeah right before it would take like
maybe like three days or four days
before i can't script yeah but i feel
the more scripting you do the better you
get at it because you understand you
know the basics of how to get a script
down right like you know i remember the
first script i wrote took me [ __ ]
forever because i was like how do you
write jokes i i've never written a joke
down in my life and performed it off the
script right so it's like
yeah so you know
i i would see like your upload schedule
and then i would see your videos and i
would think to myself all right if i
were to make this video how long would
it take for me yeah and then i think to
myself yeah it'll probably take even
longer than it probably took gone yeah
right and that's why i've never really
seen a problem with your upload schedule
if anything i think like i'm i'm
honestly even thinking like for next
year i'm thinking to maybe go to like
something similar to your upload
schedule as well because i want to put
because i think this year the thing
that's changed in my channel is that
like i've definitely upped my quality of
content or like yeah i've upped the bar
of the minimum standard that a video
should be yeah and that has resulted in
videos not only taking longer to make
yeah and to edit for mood on but also
it's taking longer to prepare just in
general yeah so it's like
right now especially these last couple
of months that i've been in like a
little bit of a burnout um i've noticed
that like
a week and one video a week is starting
to get tough i i actually forgot i had
to upload the other day yeah right i was
so busy i mean especially with us
legitimately yeah you just forgot to
upload the video and then the day i was
like it was like midnight and i was like
oh i could upload it right now because
it was supposed to go up in three hours
but i had to wake up at 4 a.m to do a
call yeah so i was like [ __ ] this i'm
not
i need like these three hours of sleep
i'm getting yeah yeah right so but it's
like especially with us too now that
we've like put more effort into our
second channels as well right yeah and
on top of trash taste every week and
then trash days after dark every week
right like
that's already so much [ __ ] on my plate
that i realized like oh if i continue
this
uh you know once a week schedule if i or
if i kind of lock myself into this once
a week schedule i'm either gonna
completely burn out yeah i'm either just
gonna be so [ __ ] exhausted that i
can't do anything or you know worst case
scenario both and the quality of my
videos is just naturally gonna go down
yeah i've been toying with the idea of
just
not uploading all january doing the
classic youtuber move oh yeah i was like
i kind of want to like just do streaming
all month so and i thought january is
the best month because that's when you
get like
ad revenue you get a zero ad revenue and
that's the youtuber month that everyone
takes off because they don't get much
money yeah yeah yeah but i was like i do
actually want to try doing like streams
uh full month see how it goes and yeah
have more of a consistent schedule with
that because i feel like i've invested a
lot in the streaming but i'm still like
in compared to other people who are
full-time streamers i'm nowhere near as
consistent yeah and i think that's one
thing that's like is a detriment to that
because people always complain like
connor i never know when the [ __ ] you're
gonna stream yeah and i'm like yeah i
know but that's what i like about it
i like that i just turn up and i'm like
all right i was gonna stream for 12
hours now casually let's do it